[Musique]
non
mon
[Musique]
nous avons peut-être pu constater qu'il
ya une forte activité de braconnage dans
ces zones et donc il fallait bien qu'on
soit présent sur le terrain pour pouvoir
réguler et réguler ses activités il faut
retenir que la chasse au gabon elle
n'est pas interdite elle est réglementée
[Musique]
on
oh
ah l'amour
il
non nous là on va me va mourir comme et
viennent mais nan hommage à la
nourriture aux villages nous on n'a pas
les le moyen ne travaille pas je ne peux
pas la retraite moment n'a pas la
retraite
[Musique]
la vente de bateaux est composé
de six heures
dans la zone anale non pas de
compensation
[Musique]
m
et
ban a beau diable ou dirigeants